-(PHONE RINGS)
-ADAM SHANK: Hello?
OPERATOR: (OVER PHONE) This call
is from a federal prison.
-Here.
-Hello, Mom.
CINDY SHANK:
I love you, princess.
RUDY VALDEZ:
Do you know why Mommy's there?
ANNALIS SHANK:
The kids that lived with her
were doing bad things,
and that's why she's there,
'cause she was actually
with those kids.
CINDY: (ON PHONE)
ADAM: The minute she heard
that door knock
and they said they had a warrant
for her arrest,
I turned around and saw her,
you know, hugging the kids.
That was tough,
because she knew already.
VALDEZ:
I wanna try and tell your story.
Figure out a way
to make something good
-out of all of this.
-CINDY: (ON PHONE)
I remember she always used
to play with me
and she used to comb my hair.
CINDY: (ON PHONE)
AUTUMN SHANK:
It has been tough
for the last nine years
without her being here.
WOMAN:
There are thousands
and thousands of people
just like her,
serving the same
ridiculously insane sentences.
She did not go to the police
so she was guilty.
What we cannot
wrap our heads around,
as a family,
as her brother, as her children,
is the sentence
that she received.
CINDY: (ON PHONE)
I carry your heart, right?
Mm-hmm. And I carry your heart.